do follow a lot of UFC you watch it
fairly closely I do but I travel a lot
as well so I missed the last one we were
in California it's just so due to travel
who do you like to watch but it's
anybody I know you're you know all of
them right now I mean I really do you
know it's very hard to pick a few names
I like John Jones to come back I would
really like to see I think he could be
the greatest of all times
I mean he lost once but that was not
really a loss right that was not a loss
yeah so so and the guy is just a
freaking nature and then fighting at
heavyweight that will sign me up you
know and with this reach and I think
it's going to be a great fight against
nangano if that's going to happen John
Jones again there is talking about it
yeah let me tell you that is an insane
pay-per-view yeah who's favored in that
fight John you
grew a lot he's doing the bank system
now boss wouldn't inspired Bank Muay
Thai you know his footwork he went to
extreme Couture that's where they teach
that system so his footwork you saw him
getting much better switching stance
he's doing all that stuff they started
getting inside his head go for takedowns
is what he did against God yeah yeah
okay so but still to stop a takedown
from Jon Jones you know it's going to be
hard he's such a great wrestler and John
Jones you know he might from the first
start whoop shoots in and take him down
right away and once that's in his head
he's going to be the you know it's going
to be hard for him to throw a punch
because he's gonna once you throw a
punch with power you have to plan your
feet right and when she Pledge Your Feet
well you set yourself up for a takedown
and they know that so if Jones comes out
immediately takes him down well he sits
he sets the tone of the fight now he's
making him worried so
connects fights over yeah what I like
about how we fought Cyril Ghana when
when Francis fought him everybody said
it's just going to be a stand-up but he
beat him on the ground which was not
super smart kind of like what you did
okay you don't think I can do it I'm
gonna go on the next eight to show you
that I can win on the ground and uh it
was listen of course this guy's punch he
was here just three months ago on the
podcast five months ago he's an animal
but uh uh he's massive no but Jon Jones
Jon Jones is in the discussion of the
greatest of all time by other greats so
they call him the great other greats
call him the greatest yeah which that's
when you know you're you're doing I just
have one question regarding Jon Jones
versus naganu how much bigger and
heavier is Nagano than Jones
[Music]
will probably be 265 on the day of the
fight but he will oh no of the day of
the fight probably 270 75. so if you're
talking 30 40 pounds I mean how much of
a difference does that make you're
talking about a lightweight fighting a
heavyweight in essence no I I fought no
weight losses right my my fight's in
Japan were no weight classes she fought
everybody you fought how much heavier he
was than him how much bigger was 65.
yeah foreign
207 against 265. 60 pounds so weight
doesn't make that much
you don't want to get hit you know but
so but you slip you you know you make
sure you don't get hit people always
said I never had an eight count I never
went down I never was knocked out you
know and they said so you don't like to
get hit I said I don't mind to get hit
but why would I let myself get hit if I
can avoid it I mean it's simple right so
just to clear the air I don't like
getting hit right is that what you're
saying no I said nobody likes to get hit
I don't mind to get hit you because I
know I have a hard head I mean no they
hit a Coca-Cola bottle like a big one on
my head and it didn't break I didn't go
down you know baseball bat with a nail
in it it didn't go down and nunchuck I
didn't go down so I I know I have a hard
hat yeah you know well this this kind of
is against what you're saying about
coaching like you could I don't know how
much coaching it takes to take a
baseball bat over the head no no that's
some natural ability that's a natural
ability I don't think yeah but being in
really good shape will help you also
with that always being a Peak
Performance like that was one of my
things that was always in great shape
and for I could keep going you know so
you weather the storm for the first four
minutes and then there's fire because
they're big you know and that's the
difference with then and now because now
you got angano which is five five
flights five rounds easy you know
there's shapes and they're freaking
Giants saying it is it is because he has
got the same long volume that I have and
the same heart that I have only he's got
way more power so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]